though John wig chapter 4 is the end of
a saga there are still more World
building that raises the stakes for
everyone's favorite dog-loving assassin
to never before seen Heights spoilers
ahead John Wick and his three sequels
have everything you could want from a
top tier action movie franchise in 10
set pieces brutal stunts some of the
best combat scenes in cinema and
mesmerizing gunfu have kept viewers
coming back for more film after film
sure other movies like Raid Redemption
Ip Man and atomic blondes have similar
attributes but what really sets John
Wick apart as the depth of the World
building the filmmaker sets up from the
very beginning in this world Assassin's
work for the mysterious high table a
governing body of faceless rulers Who
oversee the most ruthless Killers known
and unknown to humanity but how can any
organization keep all of those killers
in line the answer is simple rules there
are specific rules in the John Wick
universe that all members of the
organization run by the high table must
follow in the first movie we see what
happens when rules are broken When Miss
Perkins conducts business on Continental
grounds and is subsequently executed for
it and of course John Wick spends
multiple movies paying for his
transgressions like any good World
building we find out a little more about
the world with every film John Wick
chapter 4 is no different as we are
treated to a couple of new rules in
Reeves later salting
ever since he got revenge for the death
of his puppy by taking out Yosef tarasov
and his father Vigo John Wickers had a
single goal getting out of the life of
course the world of the high table
doesn't make that easy and his pursuit
of Freedom goes off the rails multiple
times we find out in John Wick chapter 4
that there is a relatively
straightforward path for getting out
from under the table in the form of a
one-on-one door with the Marquee coming
down on him and hunting him into a
corner his only chance to get out to
succumb face to face with the one person
standing between him and Freedom the
concept of a high table duel had always
been a mess to John but Winston reveals
that they are in fact real and that Jon
needs to rejoin the Roma rescue family
in order to request one challenge him to
single combat what a lose it's a way out
the door provides audiences with an
opportunity for a fitting end for our
hero and it takes us back to the old
rules of what is assumed to be a very
old organization while the doll focuses
on the challenged and the Challenger
each has to provide a second as well
when Winston John second delivers the
Declaration to the Marquee the scheming
villain reveals that while the loser of
the fight faces death his number two is
bound to the same fate as representative
that is number two Winston takes
responsibility for delivering John to
the duel on Time Winston has been
hitching his wagon to the fate of John
Wick for three movies so it should come
as no surprise that the man would do so
again in the final moments and risk
everything on the back of Wix brutality
if Wick is the victor of the door
Winston is reinstated as a manager of
the Continental if Wick loses both of
their lives are forfeit there is a deep
law that the world of John Wick provides
to go along with some of the best action
set pieces in all of Cinema the lore and
the rules that come with it help
establish impossibly high stakes for
John Wick but by the end of chapter 4
even our titular hero can't escape their
south of the high table
[Music]